hey guys I'm Walter Brennan Ike and
welcome to top 5 here we countdown the
best and worst performances of our most
beloved actors today we take a look at
the best of everyone's favorite human
cartoon Jim Carrey Jim Carrey has been
in the public eye for decades now even
though many people know him for the
crazy comedic characters he's played he
also has some fantastic dramatic roles
to his credit this guy has some great
range and these are his top 5 best
performances number 5 stanley ipkiss /
the mask in the mask this number 5 spot
had a few contenders but well put the
mask over the top is the fact that
Carrey got to cut loose in this role
like none before or after when timid
bank clerk stanley ipkiss discovers a
magical mask
containing the spirit of the Norse god
Loki Loki who's Loki I am a god you dull
creature his entire life changes while
wearing the mask if this becomes a
supernatural playboy exuding charm and
confidence which allows him to catch the
eye of local nightclub singer Tina
Carlyle unfortunately under the mask his
influence if kiss also robs a bank which
angers jr. crime lord Dorian Tyrell
whose goons get blamed for the heist
so Carrey plays two roles in this movie
we have stanley ipkiss and the mask
himself he starts out not so great as if
kiss it seems like he's holding back in
the straight man character I'm sure that
was done to boost the appeal of the mask
and his anus that comes out later in the
movie but he's played fantastic straight
man characters before that were very
engaging this one takes a while to warm
up however as the film goes on it kiss
becomes more interesting and it turns
into a very solid role for care of
course the real reason why this is on
the list is because of his performance
as the mask
and pa rt why because I gotta somebody's
stopped me
this guy's encouraged of oh this must
have been a dream come true for the guy
he got to play a real-life cartoon
character everything from his movements
to his expressions still showing through
the makeup reveal probably his most
purely entertaining and I think in some
respects underrated role he's ever done
I wish we had more of him as the mask in
this movie it just feels like that
character deserved more screentime hey
maybe they'll make a sequel got cold
number four
Ace Ventura and Ace Ventura pet
detective 1994 was Carrie's breakout
year this the mask and Dumb and Dumber
all came out then an Ace Ventura might
still be what Carey is best known for
that character is pretty much the
epitome of his crazy side it's all him
unfiltered in the best way when the
dolphin mascot of Miami's NFL team is
abducted Ace Ventura a zany private
investigator who specializes in finding
missing animals looks into the cakes
soon Miami Dolphins players are
kidnapped too including star player Dan
Marino making aces sleuth work even more
pressing working with dolphins
representative Melissa Robinson ace
closes in on the culprits but not before
many ridiculous misadventures Carrey
comes out of the gate swinging in this
and it lasts the whole film his energy
is infectious and it carries the film
past mediocrity and put him on
everyone's radar
what makes this role very strong for
Carey is that Ventura is not an idiot
he's obviously super eccentric but he's
also very smart and competent not just
some fool Kari gave him just a touch of
depth that's all I needed the memorable
lines are complemented by Carey's
impeccable physical humor alrighty then
have exorcised the demons let's see that
in an instant replay her overall he's
more well-rounded here than in the mask
and this is just a better movie the
laughs don't stop if you've never seen
this one go back and check out why
Carrie became so popular in the first
place
number three Joel barish in Eternal
Sunshine of the spotless mind I love
this movie this is probably my favorite
film on the list Carrie gives an
important career performance here
his introverted portrayal of a man
giving up on love and one by one losing
the memories of that love have him run
the gamut of varying powerful emotions
after a painful breakup Clementine
undergoes a procedure to erase memories
of her former boyfriend Joel from her
mind when Joel discovers that Clementine
is going to extremes to forget the
relationship he undergoes the same
procedure and slowly begins to forget
the woman that he loved
directed by former music video director
Michel Gondry and written by Charlie
Kaufman the visually arresting film
explores the intricacy of relationships
and the pain of loss this quiet shy Jim
Carrey works just as well if not even
better in this film then most of the
other kooky characters that people know
him better for Joel is a relatable
likable and flawed character all these
different elements are made present in
several scenes with minimal lines from
Carrie his face and body language do a
lot of the heavy lifting there are
points when Kerri manically tries to
hold on to the individual memories
before they're erased and those scenes
are fantastic he's nervous he's scared
and in an impossible situation to
imagine he just nails it
there are several relationships shown in
this movie with Joel and clementines
Kate Winslet feeling the most organic
everyone is great in this movie even the
smaller roles but Kate Winslet should
not be overlooked in she's amazing in
eternal sunshine this may be Carrie's
movie but Winslet almost outshines him
at times
I'll admit that the movie itself is so
unique in surreal yet familiar and
authentic that itself is better than
Kerry's performance the whole movie
doesn't exactly hinge on him like number
two and three do on this
I noticed something new every time I
watch it truly something special if you
think Kerry can't pull off a serious
role go watch Eternal Sunshine of the
spotless mind it's my top recommendation
as a film but Kerry himself is better in
two more roles number two Truman Burbank
in The Truman Show the concept for this
movie is very intriguing it's just
outside the grasp of reality but when
you look at the idea behind the Truman
Show are we really that far there's so
much for Kerry to sink his teeth into
here he gets to be funny he gets to be
serious it's really the best of both
worlds for him in a great movie he
doesn't know it but everything in Truman
Burbank sly fizz part of a massive TV
set executive producer Christoph
orchestrates The Truman Show a live
broadcast of Truman's every move
captured by hidden cameras Christoph
tries to control Truman's mind even
removing his true love celia in the show
and replacing her with merrill as truman
gradually discovers the truth however he
must decide whether to act up Truman is
lovably goofy in this without coming off
as obnoxious like Carrie can sometimes
get the name of the game behind this
performance are the layers behind it
he plays Truman as the world sees him
and he plays the real man underneath who
hates his surroundings and is trying to
plan his way out of town all those
conversations with himself and little
things that he thinks nobody hears is
very nuanced carry handles it well
nearly perfect he's innocent but
determined as the story moves along what
he suspects that something is off that's
when another layer comes out this is
more manic more wild up he wants answers
and is starting to become more
spontaneous even questions those around
it what the hell are you talking about
who are you talking to I've tasted other
Koko's this is the best what the hell
does this have to do
tell me what's happening The Truman Show
is a lot of fun it asks important
questions while being quirky enough to
keep it light check it out if you have
and as Truman would say good afternoon
good evening and good day and the number
one best Jim Carrey performance is Andy
Kaufman in man on the moon this is the
only role I've ever seen Jim Carrey
completely disappear in there's no sign
of him anywhere he becomes Andy Kaufman
and that's good enough Jim Carrey stars
as the late Andy Kaufman who was
considered one of the most innovative
eccentric and Ignat matic performers of
his time a master at manipulating
audiences Kaufman could generate belly
laughs Tony silenced tears or brawls
whether inviting the audience out for
milk and cookies or challenging women to
enter gender wrestling matches he
specialized in creating performances so
real that even his close friends were
never sure where the truth lay any
Kaufman was a weird dude to jump inside
that guy psyche could not have been easy
he didn't think about things the way
other entertainers did he was very
different in the style of his comedy and
his personality in general Carrey fully
committed to the madness and the result
is something transcendent when compared
to his other work his story is
ultimately tragic however the joy
Kaufman brought to his friends and fans
is displayed very well in this film his
spirit was there and if you compare
Carrie's performance here to old videos
of Kaufman it's really uncanny the
things Kaufman did were fascinating from
the creation of his alter ego Tony
Clifton to the video play of his funeral
Jim Carrey plays him with great respect
authenticity and a big heart
not long ago rumors were swirling that
Andy Kaufman was alive a few of his
friends claimed he faked his death as
one last big prank on everybody
while Kaufman didn't rise from the grave
the fact that this was a major news
story for a few weeks
proves he has a lasting legacy Jim
Carrey became a part of that legacy with
man on the moon not the best film on
this list but that performance is too
incredible to ignore I hope that Carrey
can do another one of these in their
future that guy can do it all I want to
hear what you guys think what is your
favorite Jim Carrey
vn performance who do you want me to
cover next on the show leave a comment
and let me know follow me on twitter at
awesome underscore Walter and come back
next week when we take a look at Jim
Carrey's top 5 worst performances until
then thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
you